(cris d'encouragement)issements)
- Face à la pression de
500 signataires victimes d'abus
allégués, Ottawa a tranché :de n
au nouveau Bureau du commissaire
à l'intégrité du sport.
Le directeur générde la fédérat,
soutient ne pas av
informé des intentions
de la ministre des
Pascale St-Onge, lorsqu'il
s'est entretenu avec elle
la semaine dernière.
Le directeur général
de Global Athlete, Rob Koehler,
y voit un pas dans la bonneme ai
que les athlètes méritent
une meilleure protection.
Leur colère s'est accentuée à dn
sexuelle alléguée à l'endroit
d'une fillette de 7 ans
par un entraîneur d'un clubridg.
Les gymnastes exigent
la création d'une instance
indépendante de traitement
PASCALE ST-ONGE,ministre fédéras
- Il est primordial
de protéger nos athlètes... mine
St-Onge affirme qu'uneinvitatioe
avec Gymnastes pour
le changement a ét. Aujourd'. A,
à l'Île-du-Prince-Édouard,le prn
Trudeau a réitéré l'importance
d'un milieu sport sécuritaire
sportifs canadiens.
Ici Jean-François